hallo leute heute möchte ich euch von
einem projekt erzählen an dem wir schon
etwas länger arbeiten und bei diesem
projekt geht es darum wie man spielend
deutschland wie ihr wisst ist es
schwierig eine sprache zu lernen ihr
wisst dass am besten es ist schwer die
grammatik zu lernen
es ist schwer vokabeln zu lernen aber es
ist dazu auch noch oft langweilig und
wir haben uns gefragt wie ist das
eigentlich oder wie toll wäre es wenn
man deutsch spielend lernen könnte es
gibt auch eine redewendung im
deutsch-deutschen etwas spielen lernen
und damit meint man so zu lernen wie
kinder lernen kinder entdecken etwas sie
spielen mit etwas und dabei lernen sie
etwas kennen und es wäre toll wenn man
auch eine sprache so intuitiv lernen
könnte dadurch dass man spielt und wie
ihr wisst haben wir von schon vor über
einem jahr eine app veröffentlicht die
heißt sie länger und dort haben wir auch
verschiedene bereiche
man kann die grammatik kennenlernen man
kann vokabeln kennenlernen aber diese
eine sache hat uns immer gefehlt
ein spiel das so unterhaltsam ist dass
man damit deutschland ohne dass man
eigentlich merkt dass man eine sprache
lernt und genau daran haben wir in den
letzten monaten gearbeitet
das spiel heißt sie lenkt regia es ist
eine interaktive quiz schau die ihr
zuhause spielen könnt und das zeigen wir
euch heute und wir zeigen dass nicht nur
euch sondern auch janosch der hat das
ganze nämlich noch gar nicht gesehen und
sie wird das jetzt gleich zum ersten mal
testen und diese fragen zum ersten mal
sehen und darauf freue ich mich schon
denn wir haben ihnen das extra nicht
gezeigt um ihn das dann im video zu
zeigen und ich wohl das letzte mal los
geht's
jahre später bereits ich bin bereit ja
und ich freue mich und groß gerade
scheinen gleich beweisen wie gut ich bin
in der tat das kannst du mal machen
jetzt wird ein gegner geladen und wir
sehen gegen wen du spielst tim themen
jetzt ihm macht die hamas bereit gegend
installieren werden es standen in
deutschland liegt das ruhrgebiet den
westen im beide gleich das ruhrgebiet
liegt natürlich an der ruhe ging also im
westen deutschlands nächster wie viel
prozent aller deutschen haben eine
krankenversicherung alle was was macht
ihr eine prozent das sind wahrscheinlich
die millionäre
das war falsch prozent aller deutschen
jetzt kannst du mal auf dem eis gucken
und materie was die leute gedacht haben
und schon china ja welches kleingeld
existiert nicht in münzen für damen zwei
zellen ja denkt doch erstmal ja aber
dann ist ihm schnell
25 aber noch logisch lösen wenn man in
deutschland wohl weiß man das doch aber
ich weiß es nicht
zwei cent münze gibt es doch wie nennt
man einen stadtteil in berlin ein kiez
bank das stimmt ja einiges in berlin
einen stadtteil einen key babbel
die frage welche deutsche stadt hat die
höchste kriminalitätsrate für dortmund
dortmund frankfurt heißt so als hätte
frankfurt die höchste wahrscheinlich
wegen dem geld spekulanten die da sitzen
was ist die beliebteste beilage der
deutschen beim grillen wir leider nein
für deutsche ist wirklich eine beilage
und ich aber team ziemlich seien dankbar
dankbarer gegner
ja ich gewinne immer machen jetzt
entscheidende letzte frage konzentrieren
ob welche amerikanische schauspielerin
ist deutscher herkunft sie weiß ganz
genau
bullock du hast recht sandra bullock ist
tatsächlich dass ihr ich freue mich aber
ich habe es nicht wirklich verdient also
ich glaube ich hätte die meisten fragen
falsch gewählt hast drei falsch hier
richtig okay aber das ist ein schlechtes
gewissen
dann spielen wir nur folge jetzt musst
du erstmal die vokabeln lernen
sieger im ring sieger im leben
schönes deutsches sprichwort
kommen wir jetzt kannst du das spiel
beenden oder du kannst vokabeln lernen
weil das sie da wird's ein bisschen
ernster natürlich nennt ihn ein prozent
auf german 200 prozent aller deutschen
haben eine lebensversicherung
haben eine krankenversicherung eine
krankenversicherung
du hast auch das lebensversicherung
geschrieben aha natürlich habe ich jetzt
muss noch ein richtig machen
35 cent korrigieren es gibt keine 25
cent münze
[Musik]
es gibt keine 25 cent münze in
deutschland sehr gut danke schön ist das
dankeschön das ist wirklich genial probe
jetzt freuen uns darauf dass ihr das
ganze selber testet ihr könnt das ganze
ausprobieren indem ihr auf den link hier
unten gc link dort kommt recht rabiat
und klickt dann mal drauf wir freuen uns
vor allem auf eure kommentare wir wollen
dass es nützlich ist dass es euch spaß
macht und wenn ihr ideen hab feedback
dann freuen wir uns darüber ganz
besonders klickt man auf den link drauf
hier und dann geht es direkt zur
siedlung und ihr könnt direkt anfangen
zu spielen
los geht's welches land grenzt nicht an
deutschland geplant natürlich noch ganz
nicht an deutschland